c'est l'histoire trois jeunes mecs des
maillettes qui après avoir suivi une
bavure policière décide d'organiser une
marche non violente de partir de mars
elle de faire une marche à travers la
france pour sensibiliser les gens et ils
vont se retrouver à la fin sans merci à
paris ces histoires des histoires de la
marche pour l'égalité comprend 6 août le
fait qu'il y avait un hommage justement
à ces marcheurs oublié qui m'a plu
c'était le potentiel cinématographique
et je trouvais que c'est une grande
histoire jetty sur les épaules de
moments tout quand ils sont arrivés à
100 milles à paris je me souviens
vaguement le bordel pour se dire d'une
fête voix et l'otan prenne donc on va
raconter et quand on m'a proposé était
il dit oui j'ai pas réfléchi
l'idée d'un habit ce n'est pas de faire
un film sincèrement engagés ou de
dénoncer quelque chose était vraiment
aussi de raconter une histoire sur le
fil qui a la volonté de rassembler le
plus de monde possible c'est pas un film
d'auteur radical purs et durs c'est pas
du tout un documentaire si l aventure
humaine qui n'intéresse comment se
fait-il que des gels face à la violence
décide à un moment donné parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de possibilité de répondre par
la violence
j'aimerais que à travers simplement se
rendre compte à quel point on est
français que moi à quel point on
revendique un tel plan mais finir
parfois quand tu fermes les yeux ça pour
être totalement des dialogues
d'aujourd'hui et je pense que c'est le
moyen aussi d'attirer des gens qui n'ont
pas connu cette époque c'est de leur
dire vous avez pas connu il en fait vous
vivez la même chose dire qu'on va faire
l'histoire sur des mecs de banlieue qui
sont non violents qui ont encore à faire
autrement dit certaines personnes
mordues heureusement que c'est une
histoire vraie parce que sinon personne
je crois
e